how do you deal with you know you know
porn obesity how do you deal with that
on a state level what do you do you're
in the government right now you're the
president what do you do I would say and
I have a whole dissertation it's called
on this by the way on my channel we go
through all the scientific research for
two hours if you don't believe me porn
is literally like a weapon it's a drug
and it's destroying it's been used in
Israel as as a particular form of life
and even in like World War II for
example it's demoralizing they would
drop propaganda of soldiers being
ravaged by the enemy Force because it
demoralizes you you know even from an
amoral perspective ignoring the
religious aspect of it you're watching
some other guy you know have sex with a
chick presumably that's what you would
like to be doing and it does actually
take a toll on you mentally it hijacks
your brain's reward circuitry it makes
you depressed so if you're a young man
and you're watching and for whatever
reason you feel depressed you feel like
you don't have a lot of energy it's
tough for you to sleep you can't make
eye contact you're socially anxious
there's literally scientific evidence
proving that that could be because of
porn don't believe me watch the video
and short-term Pleasures as well which
people are more open to and it also just
destroys and Fries your dopamine factors
in your bank I agree that's the problem
like obesity it's a big problem how do
you like like I understand we get it how
do you deal with this problem as as like
a status uh if a status
but from from like a state level you
know a state doesn't mean you're a state
you could you could easily pass your
status too okay you can easily pass
legislation just simply regulating it
the same way that we we regulate CP you
know like okay if you're gonna watch
this maybe you're 18 years old fine but
we're gonna make it so miners can't
access it because the average age that
children are being exposed to it when
their brains are the most plastic and
malleable is like nine years old and
that's assuming a normal distribution
which means 50 or even younger than nine
years old and the effects of that are
very bad I mean now it's even tough for
them to do studies on people's brains
because they can't find a control group
who hasn't been exposed to pornography
because it's so pervasive um and so I
think you could easily regulate it like
that and people want to say oh well I
don't want to have to put in my driver's
license to like watch porn it's like
dude nine-year-old you know like who
cares if you want to like jerk off to
something to pray like find but like
we're trying to protect kids here and
there is something to be said about
establishing barriers like you used to
have to go to the VHS store things like
that making it more difficult for people
to do things that are bad is good or
even with the food you go to Europe you
lose 10 pounds why is that yeah they
don't put crap in their food like we do
and we've tried so hard to find the
villain whether it's fats carbohydrates
red meat the villain is that you're
eating chemicals that your body doesn't
know how to digest it's predominantly
because of Bill Gates and Monsanto
buying up the the lobbyist industry and
going after the regulators and putting
their people in charge that allows them
to do all this crazy stuff yes but you
know this this is the problem because
you know it does need to be dealt with
and I think these are quantifiable
problems that do need to be addressed we
hear we hear we hear this a lot and it's
come up quite a bit that uh there are
people we know friends friends of people
who work here who say that when they're
outside the U.S they eat this diet they
eat their normal diet and they're thin
they come to the US and they eat the
same food and they gain 30 pounds over
like instantly and then we were like oh
maybe you don't realize the portions are
bigger maybe you started drinking and
and the response I hear all the time is
like no I eat the same thing and then we
even had one person be like when I went
back home for six months the weight
vanished like dude I'm eating the same
thing yeah and people are adamant I
don't know people also just lack a lot
of willpower these days no they're gonna
blame it on the ingredients those are
toxic ingredients in food but also like
dude shut your mouth and stuff no no the
ingredients are banned in Europe I
understand the same ingredients and I
want us to have stricter regulations on
it but also like just have some more
willpower well here's the thing I think
as an American you should be able to
just like be lazy and go to a McDonald's
and get a burger without having to worry
about it like poisoning you and making
you like effeminate I think you should
be able to do that but you can't do that
now in this country because
you can do that no no but people are
stupid no one's ever going to be like I
mean look at the average weight of like
a man in this country I I would love if
people could do that but they just won't
and they're going here and it's going up
dramatically so here's here's the issue
though if people people are not apt
enough Savvy enough knowledgeable enough
to avoid eating that garbage is it the
responsibility of the government to ban
them from eating it I believe so
absolutely I mean that's what is the
government's job that's not to look out
for the people that's Mike Bloomberg's
position yes I'm not entirely saying
you're wrong I'm just letting you know
like yeah Bloomberg right he wanted to
ban sodas sugary drinks and he even went
as far as say tax the poor because they
buy things that are bad for them so we
should take more of their money away and
then spend it on things that are good
for them yeah that I don't think I don't
think I would want to tax it but I think
there are ways to cut subsidies to
things that are bad and redirect them
towards things that are good you know
the American died in the 1950s now we
would scoff at like oh all this red meat
and everything they were significantly
healthier than we are now I mean we are
eating literal poisons and endocrine
disruptors and Cancers and we wonder why
everybody's so depressed the two things
that your brain is the most wired to
pursue food and sex have been hijacked
such that now like we said the average
American is an overweight like
hypersexual porn addicted slob that's
not good
to uh I went to a restaurant and for
dessert they had a bread pudding and I
was like oh that sounds good like you
guys have had bread pudding before right
yeah yeah it was basically it was that
they brought it out it was one of the
most amazing things I've ever eaten in
my life mind you and it was this small
it was very small
but it was six Krispy Kreme Donuts
compressed into a small cake and then
covered with like with like sweetened
condensed milk and like a cherry and
then I was like I tried and I was like
this tastes like Krispy Kreme I was like
wait a minute you could see that it was
like they took a half dozen donuts it's
got to be like 1200 calories in this
thing that's insane that was like a
regular dessert for one person so just
it was delicious if I could somebody
your argument correct me if I'm wrong
sure you're saying human beings are
imperfect they they can't rule their own
life so we need government to rule the
lives for them but isn't the government
made up of those same imperfect
individuals that's my my argument is not
that like you know people can't be
trusted with Liberty people can't be
trusted with free I'm saying that this
stock of people that we've assembled
because we have failed to prevent evil
forces from instituting Evil things is
now at a state where I'm not saying they
can't be trusted with freedom I think
people are able to feed themselves I
just think that we should and we do have
an obligation to cut off the ability of
people to be able to destroy themselves
as easily with
but with food with pornography things
like that it's like yeah I think that
the government should step in and just
make food real again make sex real again
make people have relationships again it
is possible to at least redirect the
trends I agree with you on the problems
but the government I I would argue
created a lot of those problems
incentivized a lot of those problems
allows a lot of those problems and this
is why I don't think the state is going
to solve those problems and I think it
should be on an individual level
led by John Doyle though so
you're both right Luke you've recognized
that we have a government that is doing
bad things that doesn't mean we just we
just say instantly that all social
factors of contract is impossible the
issue is that corruption takes hold and
something has to be done about it so I
view it like this uh what you're saying
is deeply nuanced John you're talking
about poison food and all these really
corrupt things they're hard to see but
at the root there's something simple
let's say you have a small village of
100 people the the the anti-statist
absolutist and this is I'm not I'm not
trying to make a straw man but if you're
absolutely anarchic and like no no there
should be no Authority no state
governments are bad they always cause
problems a barbarian horde comes in and
they destroy everything there's no
social understanding there's no pact or
a fire burns down a house and people say
screw you I'm not going to help you no
no the the earliest form of government
isn't inherently a bad thing it's the
centralization of authority and the
corruption of government that's a bad
thing if you have a small village of 100
people and there's a social
understanding between all of them as to
how things are run what is okay and what
isn't you've got the basics of
governance your community the problem is
we have no Community left in this
country it's been totally shattered and
thus what we're seeing now with the
Democrats
and the Republicans
they're calling it The Basement strategy
Hobbs didn't campaign they just said get
as many votes as possible it doesn't
matter what you say to these people no
longer are elections based on the social
contract they're based on playing to the
rules to the best of the ability of the
player Republicans didn't understand
this in the midterms still managed to
get the house now they're starting to
realize that hey you don't need to
campaign at all just get enough people
to collect as many votes as possible in
whatever the legal mean is door-to-door
as certified caregivers and get people
to vote for you that's all that matters
yeah that's not a tenable government
that that's not going to work there's
also something to be said about the
political incentive that we have because
so much of what the left does like we
hit on earlier is just create and
manufacture the victim narratives and
everybody's a victim everyone's in
Despair and if you look at like what
unites these people it's much less
ideology and much more just the shared
misery and hatred against those who they
cast as like their dad or whoever was
like mean to them in their life or
something and when you have a person who
is overweight whose dopamine has been
fried there depressed that person is so
much more likely to want to sympathize
and resonate with those victim
narratives because they tell themselves
through their narcissism like I because
somebody like looked at me once in a
Victoria's Secret because I'm overweight
I'm like just as oppressed as black
people or something like that and when
you have people who are overweight
especially young people we're so
overweight Now where's the Revolution
going to be fought I mean the young
people are the future testosterone too
because of the endocrine disruptors in
the food is down 40 in the last 40 years
when your testosterone goes down you
become more agreeable you're amygdala in
your brain these chemicals have been
shown over time to shrink your amygdala
which is the part of your brain that is
responsible for saying things like no
and not coincidentally the average
person in this country has been far more
agreeable to things that would be
Unthinkable to our grandparents
generation so I believe that people can
be trusted with Liberty but I also think
that we should probably stop evil people
from doing evil things and then if
people want to overeat that's fine but
they do have an incentive to make you
fat and weak and depressed let me ask
you a question Luke right uh a serious
question in like an anarchy City like or
in a place like Sharon how do they deal
with someone who is coming with a gun
and robbing people
um they have Community networks of
people who actually are are security
guards who are responsible for the
mutual protection so coming in the city
you go through you know a checkpoint and
you can't have any kind of political
signs you can't have any kind of
political ideology and they have a
community watch uh which protects them
and the crime has gone down absolutely
dramatically they haven't had a murder
in many years now and when they deal
with crime they deal it with they deal
with it in a sensible level where of
course if someone is doing a crime
because of an addiction they help that
person deal with the addiction rather
than of course just punishing them and
making them worse how do they deal with
fraud
um I'm not I don't have any examples of
that particular uh example at all so I
don't know so the the challenge is it's
really easy to be like obviously taking
someone's belongings is a bad thing and
we have we've developed Civics around
how to deal with these things can you
prove it are there Witnesses the
standards vary from country to country
but typically if I take something from
you I am causing damage to you we
understand that if I strike you and
they're witnessing you instigated the
fight we understand that but what if
you're doing something that's like uh
scamming them out of their money
something like that's fraudulent in the
United States deception in order to
steal their resources I I'll I'll ask my
contacts in Tehran and come back to you
with a particular answer on that but but
the reason I ask is because some things
are uh are illegal that some people
think shouldn't be illegal and some
things are legal that should be illegal
and how is that understood by the people
of Sharon for instance what if someone
buys 10 roosters and puts them in their
house and they're screaming all day long
clearly people are going to be upset
with it what if someone goes outside and
gets an l-rad and just blasts the sound
of the time is it because they say we've
determined what you're doing to be
unreasonable regardless of whether or
not we've agreed you can't do it
obviously blasting an l-red device is
damaging but hey hey come on I want
roosters no you can't tell me I can't
have roosters they're my animals and I'm
going to eat them and I need them yeah
so if they're you know I'm not arguing
for outright authoritarianism but I do
think a basic understood social contract
where we where we understand each other
is is a valuable thing yeah it's just
simple the one of the main principles of
of anarchist is don't take people's
stuff don't steal and don't hurt other
people and I think if we just live by
those principles and we respect those
principles the world will be different
and you know when it comes to especially
what's happening with modern males I
would argue that there is a an agenda
meant to demasculate people meant to
destroy people meant to create a public
that is never going to stand up against
the tyranny of the state meant to of
course make them acquiesce with
everything like you said and it's not
just testosterone levels it's also sperm
levels it's also grip strengths we are
being biologically attacked topped down
in almost every element of our life that
is destroying modern manhood to the
point where women now have better grip
strength and even more testosterone than
more most males no so why why is it
important
that's not true look that is not true
we've we've actually talked about grip
strike grip strength on the show and
pulled up studies showing showing the
relative grip strength in specifically
referring to the differences between
males and females males have stronger
grip strength absolutely but but but now
this this this kind of chart is changing
right so so now yeah males have have
stronger average grip strength
is going up up right yes and so the same
with the testosterone levels so so is
that important like why would it be
important for women to become more
disagreeable and have more time it's not
I'm just I'm just I'm just I'm just
that's part of a planned agenda what I'm
describing here is the Takeover of the
state because I think at the end of the
day the state is doing this because the
state needs people to acquiesce with it
and the state has an agenda that is
pushing this agenda to have more people
that they could rule over because again
the the government the state is a
corporation they want to make sure they
have the most clients who's going to be
the best client of the state the people
who need it the most and this is why
there's been an agenda to make the
people need the state more and more than
ever I agree with that I think that this
state is hostile towards the people over
whom it governs but I don't think it's
because it is the state I think it's
because it was infiltrated by Communists
and Communists or evil people like
that's what they want they want Global
communism they're very open about this
uh it's conspiratorial when we say it
but then you read the forms in the you
know the world economic Forum they're
like completely open about it they brag
about it they write dissertations and
papers saying we need Global control we
need totalitarianism
this seems to get back to the point that
we were talking about earlier with like
okay we have the state it sucks it's
hostile towards us well now what do we
do what are we supposed are we supposed
to just tell it it should delete itself
are we supposed to take power and then
delete the state like I don't think that
anarchy has an actual answer to the
problem because like you said if
everyone just stops stealing everything
would be fine so true now try to tell
that to like illegal aliens what are you
going to hand them like copies of like
Thomas Paine literature and be like hey
you should really you know read some of
this they just aren't receptive without
the welfare state we wouldn't have a lot
of this immigration that's true so I
think that's another argument that
deserves to be made here specifically
when it comes to the state incentivizing
a lot of this nonsense incentivizing a
lot of the these divide and conquer
agendas again no one has the perfect
solution here but at the end of the day
I think the more pragmatic thing is
calling for decentralization
decentralization of power not Central
realization of power giving people more
opportunities to move away from this
fifth generational warfare that's
affecting them because the more you
empower the state the more you empower
the agenda against yourself I think
that's true I also think there is
something to be said about taking over
the state and like using it to benefit
ourselves and you know we had a good
system in this country it wasn't perfect
but it was a lot better than the system
we have now and I think if we allow that
stock of people to retain power things
would be far better off for everybody I
respect your opinion you make very good
arguments but I believe that's a pipe
dream well all right I guess we'll I
guess we'll see I I think you know one
thing I've learned over the past several
years is that uh there is no end point
or I should I suppose I should say it's
a developed idea I've learned more and
more about over a long period of time
but you know I often say the ends don't
justify the means because you never meet
the ends which is to say that you may
come up with this document that says
like here's the perfect government and
on paper it makes sense you begin to
implement it and things improve a
hundred years later you live in a
corrupt garbage country based on that
document and people are like see it
didn't work and you're like no no it
worked for as long as it did and then
humans are fallible creatures that's
just that's just it the assumption that
humans can can adhere to a perfectly
rigid system is it's just not the case
yeah and so this is sort of I think the
crossroads we're at where it's like okay
either we keep telling people that small
government is the answer things like
that and then maybe one of these days we
somehow managed to get the government to
shrink or we decentralize the power or
we actually try to do what they did the
Long March through the institutions take
back power and then the argument is well
then how what's to stop them from doing
it okay then we're back at square one we
voted all our guys into office and then
they become Communists and then we're
just back by square one I'm gonna back
Luke with one simple solution uh um I
think you'll agree in a sense
let me ask you this if everyone every
single person in this country was a
Conservative Christian would you need
police
at a very small scale right the issue
really is are we a cohesive culture yeah
do we do we agree with each other do we
uh do we uh have the same values if you
have a community that shares its values
you really don't have to leave your
doors open assuming your values are like
don't harm other people don't steal from
them the problem is we have no shared
values so people are turning to
government for the solution when the
solution is actually cultural but so I
agree with you with a long march to the
institutions we need our media apparatus
mostly to basically speak to people and
tell them like
here are the things that we share and I
don't mean like a top-down broadcast
tower of like the five journalists I
mean we need a we need a dominant
culture to emerge explain why what it
does works when the arguments win the
institutions and then say like this is
what we as a community are here for
and then I don't think you need to rely
on powerful governments or big
government and what's interesting about
that too is like the biggest I should
say the closest that we came to really
living in that kind of post-racial
society was probably after 9 11. I mean
everybody was United under the American
flag maybe for the wrong reasons uh so
maybe something to talk about that no do
I don't want to talk about that one you
had things like you know the Chappelle
show for example when and Dave's still
relevant where he was making fun of
every group equally pretty much you had
things like WWE everyone loved Eddie
Guerrero like John Cena put out a rap
album but you're more allowed to sorry
to interrupt but I just want to address
the one point before we move on from it
there were a lot of Arabic people who
are being discriminated against and and
and feared yeah because of terrorism
well I should say post-racial in the
sense of sex as well America's always
been pretty much a biracial country and
the Hispanics started coming here after
65 but yeah there was a lot of anti-arab
discrimination but uh in terms of like
you know the traditional American
demographics I guess I would say we
really did kind of have a period where
it seemed like it wasn't going to be as
problematic and then now they refuse to
let us acknowledge as those differences
which do exist because they believe that
all people are fundamentally the same
and so you can't joke about them you
can't acknowledge them and if you do you
get canceled yeah I I think also just to
continue this kind of larger
conversation I wasn't prepared for a
debate but when you made those pothead
statements those those shots fired
you're like hey man I don't I don't
smoke weed I don't use weed personally
myself but I do think one of the the the
weaker elements of of Anarchy and
libertarianism is when it comes to
specifically children I do believe
children deserve to be protected uh I do
believe that there should be elements
and institutions in charge that protect
children from uh what's what's online
from other Predators from other people
taking advantage of them from other
people trying to hurt them
psychologically physically and mentally
who is the the was it Austin Peters
Peterson he was on the debate stage when
someone said legalize heroin for
children and he said no and he's known
as the guy saying no utilizing Harem for
children because he said he wouldn't do
that now again I I I I think there
should be protections for children
obviously uh because children aren't
consenting adults and I think there's a
lot of predators out a lot of
Libertarians would call that into
question too absolutely exactly and that
and this is where I stand differently uh
this is this is where I disagree with
some of the larger ethos and the larger
philosophies I just wanted to make that
clear because we're talking about this
and uh I think it's a fascinating
conversation thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time